overall sir
your weapon
zane chris congratulations you boys have
made it into the final round of this
competition
now we're sending you back to your home
for just to recreate an iconic weapon
from history
that weapon is
the revolutionary war sergeant spontoon
hmm good luck
we'll see you in four days
we're back in waxhaw and i have to make
a sergeant's sponton
i decide to use 5160 for the blade steel
because it is relatively easy to heat
treat but also holds up very well
when under duress
my main goal is to elongate this piece
of steel that will eventually become the
blade
so that it meets the requirements yeah
it's a slow press
but it's okay
i'm back at my home forge i'm ready to
get started i'm excited
i'm gonna build a damascus billet i'm
gonna try to get as many layers as i can
i think it'll impress the judges and
hopefully hold up
really well in the tests i got my main
billet cleaned up
i'm gonna cut it and restack it get it
to the size i need and then i can
hopefully start getting the point shaped
out
day two i'm going to be working on the
socket getting that more fit and
finished
i'm also going to grind and hopefully
heat treat my blade for the heat treat
i'm going to be using this
oven right here it works really well
with temperature control
i can keep my blade exactly the
temperature that i want it for how long
i want it
i am nervous that my heat treat is not
going to go well
i could have the blade snap i could have
it warp i could have it just
not harden at all
i don't hear any tinking sounds so
that's good tanks are usually cracks
and it's hard and i am so excited
that was scary yesterday i got the cross
guard
and the spear to shape the cross guard
being
a separate piece is a concern of mine i
am going to have to forge weld that
for structural integrity reasons
probably going to get into some
welding with the mig welder just to
reinforce everything
and hopefully after that get it ready
for a feet treat
day three is here i plan on finishing up
my blade
and then i am going to weld my tang
and my guard to my socket that's pretty
good
it's day four on my sponton build the
first thing i gotta do today
is get the half cut out and shape down
i layered the wood up hopefully the
difference in grain structure
will help in strengthness and
flexibility
i left it sort of octagonal um i think
it would give a little better grip
now it's time to get my half attached to
my uh sponton
spearhead there's a hell of a build i'm
tired i'm sore
i think it looks awesome
i cut one i'm good all right
ladies welcome to the kill test
[Music]
now we'll take your weapon deliver some
thrust and slashes on this
wild boar carcass stay in your first you
ready for this
ready as i'll ever be
all right zayn let's talk about your
weapon here first up your tip
is really made to thrust it punctures
really deep when i'm thrusting with it
but i can move with this weapon you have
a good balance here the edge here
is sharp as you can see those are very
very deep sharp cuts
overall sir your weapon will kill
thank you doug all right chris it's your
turn you ready
yes sir
all right chris so about your weapon
here what i love about this
is when you're thrusting i can feel the
weight in front
and crunch ribs as it's penetrating
overall sir your weapon will kill
thank you sir
all right gentlemen say hello to my
little friend
to test the strength and durability of
your blades we're going to be firing
them out of our air cannon here
into that wooden wall all right zane
europe first
this thing is gonna launch my sponton my
baby
at a wall of wood i'm an odd mixture
between
excited and nervous right now in
three two one fire
all right zane nothing came apart it
still has
the edge that it started out with oh no
good job
thank you nice job all right chris
you're up
firing in three two one fire
good job chris
okay your weapon went righty between
those boards so it actually took all the
impact
up here on these lugs everything's still
straight
still sharp i really like that pattern
you've got on there nicely done
thank you look it's nice
[Music]
all right bladesmiths welcome to the
sharpness test the
coat stab and slice
to test the sharpness of your edge i
will take your weapon and slash and stab
across
this red coat saying your first let's do
it
[Music]
all right zayn your edges are sharp on
the swing of that it does cut
but what i do find here
there's a little bit of a glinting at
your tip that catches on my nails it
rolled a little bit
right there at your tip but otherwise
sir
it will cut thank you
all right chris your turn let's do this
things have uh actually been really even
between zane and i
i just hope it's my sponton it's strong
and sharp enough
this is it
[Music]
[Music]
all right chris this is a very razor
sharp blade
every slash and thrust was a deep
cut i do not see any damage to your edge
overall sir this weapon will cut
thank you zayn chris you guys have done
fantastic work on these finale
weapons but there can only be one forged
and fire champion the judges have made
their final decision
and that forged and fire champion is
chris congratulations you are the new
forged and fire champion
congratulations man zane unfortunately
your weapon took some damage during the
sharpness test which affected
the efficacy of your cuts for that
reason i'd like to invite you to shake
my hand
shake your judge's hand and then please
leave the forge come on my friend
meet you guys good job brother i did not
win but
that's okay it's a great weapon i came
here to prove that i was able to
compete with some of the big dogs and i
think i've made my point
i hope that i'll be able to keep
improving upon my craft and just get
better and better
chris you crafted a better weapon that
held up through the tests
congratulations you were the forging
fire champion and that's a title that
comes with a check
for ten thousand dollars good job
brother come over here and shake our
hands absolutely
i just came fortune fire champion that's
crazy
i'm like turning inside out right now i
got the bragging rights man
i can just keep moving ahead uh keep
doing what i'm doing
you